is this your car
it's not your car
whose car is it
police body cam video showing moments
leading up to the arrest of ex-nfl star
marshawn lynch on suspicion of dui video
you saw first inside the eight news now
app thank you so much for joining us
here at four i'm kirstjen joyce and i'm
christian casarez let's get right out to
the i-team's david charns he has more of
that footage and the new response from
lynch's attorneys david well christian
and kirsten the video appears to show
marshawn lynch sleeping there in the
driver's seat of what police call a
quote undrivable carrying you'll see why
here as an officer walks up to that car
around 7 30 tuesday you see lynch there
in the yellow the car had no rim or tire
on the front wheel there you see at the
bottom of your screen
and it appears that the wheel was about
to fall off officers say lynch was
uncooperative and would not get out of
the car which led to this take a look
driving the cars
what is the problem
i'm just asking what's the problem no he
kind of gave us
[Music]
roll over
lynch's booking photo right there on the
right side of your screen his attorneys
richard schoenfeld and david chesnov
telling me in a statement marchand was
not pulled over for a dui rather the
vehicle was safely parked in not in
operation now that is true because the
car was not on but it was a button turn
on car and police say the keys were
there with lynch you can watch the
entire arrest right now on 8newsnow.com
lynch's court day not until december i'm
david charns 8 news now